1:11 to 108 Lakers 326 at County bangs -
Howard the big man has been a force in
the middle Hardaway Botha's big mystery
throwing yes sir big mystery sir
[Applause]
the fourth and final and Dwight Howard
getting the law pratap oh and that cuts
the wizard lead to eight
Dwight watch denims
[Applause]
but I'm out at Philips
Dennis Schroder pinpoint precision on
the past Fraser turning the corner
Tennessee's speed allowed him to get to
that ball
longest journey begins with the first
step and a blocked by Howard sets up a
monster jam on the moon and his shrewder
hooks it up to Timmy his floater is an
airball but picked up and lodged by
Dwight Howard Tim Hardaway back to done
around the world
followed by Howard where he says moving
battling tune us out of the way down
around the basket the white is off to a
nice start jar here they're big fans
plague big Dwight Howard owns the
offensive glass early at teo got in the
air nowhere to go Howard picks it off
ahead to Dennis he will bake it off the
part of Howard jabs a timeout Minnesota
which off the hot pick-and-roll with
Millsap now bayes's jammed up
welcome back mr. Howard on his brother
game shoot we met her recently from
Crete and he's still gonna work Howard
this swats it away
lots of contact with Paul trying to draw
the fourth on
Isiah Thomas beautiful feet computer see
they got several players to build around
to bribe Parker look like this get a
[Music]
[Applause]
spot in traffic now puts it on the deck
rocks and they had to erase it as Dwight
Howard Bay's board defendant had Dwight
knocks it back to Marietta
[Applause]
Hardaway again they finally get it it's
white he'll Jam it you've got that to
the right offer a broken play AB on the
weak side
der couch over plays Howard has the pick
and ran away with it at half court
Howard will get it back 20 to shoot
Howard rules today 30:28 to 19 here's
Prince his second
let's keep fronting the Hawks go right
over the top look for the white Howard
in this game after they take it away
from taobao tennis steals it back and
white house
well the slam to start the Hawks none
it's over but you know it yeah you're
absolutely right but you got to live
with that on the law Dwight with the
game ball Tyrone one Hanson Milius over
three Dwight the offensive rebound
[Applause]
on our Facebook we just went to traffic
[Applause]
silly in this series until tonight he
has been a tremendous one attacking the
rim providing an offensive spark here
for the hometown in turnovers on each
side the back end by law
[Applause]
this one the white Howard that was a
good call good no-call there looked like
he got it right at the egg fence
the Hornets down by five
[Applause]
with five personal fouls treadmill
offensive
[ __ ]
without fits the board got in just a
half a second two hours only made one
three-pointer so far this season Lake
Griffin again banging against Marvin
rock away
Dwight Howard just took it away from Lou
Williams Minnesota's got the basketball
Gibson pump was the past get the
rejection in second and the Hornets have
it back shots and keep it in bounds that
is a double whammy look at that Oh throw
it out big fella let him know he won't
about scored the Hornets six to nothing
he is bouncy tonight they're up on
fertile
oh that's doing your personnel big fella
the bottom up now I've put a dribble out
cross over and dumped on Ibaka
that is a coaster good ball movement and
the hands of that guy shot clocks at for
[Applause]
the hands of the big fella and get out
of the way it calls but changes face up
it's time no need for a crossover just a
quick step to the left and you've got
another two shot clock sit boy
Dwight Howard Oh
oh my goodness goodness I thought you
might I got shoes caught up for
something that was just nasty look at
the minutes snapping around picked up by
Batum
yep the twos got to get in this game
Williams throws it up an hour throws it
down with the foul and Howard with a
chance for the three-point play and you
don't have an outside game or mid-range
game when I'm opening and the man is
playing behind me will you please throw
me the ball
Lopez two on the shot clock
and finally cleared by the Hornets
[Applause]
let's start if I hear the defensive in
the inspect that does not matter
recovers and then three guys protected
tore it down yeah big fella have already
gone nine people in their rotation right
here link controls Lopez Commission
Howard with the rebound
Rustin Rex e-cig right now left big toe
right Howard baseline at baseline Newby
you're smiling you don't believe is okay
not just what he's looking to pass the
wall of people alright when you knocked
it away but then he gives it there cuz
he'll stop and shoot the thing they all
do that
well make them bet on a running suit
yeah that's what you want to see you
want to see when he rolls down in there
and they play behind Howard's where the
Saints sheet form job is just a little
more experienced in our first quarter
look at Kim a walker right over the top
of the white house a little bit is 11
Howard faces up Arnold Quinn
[Applause]
he says to
he says up gang next possession with a
quick moving baseline refers it tore it
down with the one poster John Hitz
Marvin
nice alley-oop good two-man game called
a veteran Marvin and honey is it back
homeland Marva the recognition Ryan hits
it comes over to stop the vaulter Maceo
grant : - no but the chefs Oakland point
guards ever Jason Kidd Jerry Pate Damian
Lillard
Dwight Howard Walker's gonna drop the D
look at John Henson goes for the block
and there's this guy right there - wait
with the throwdown anticipation is e
pitch to pass away like your work choice
[Applause]
this could have been one minute
Tatum tried to go
[Applause]
why Howard keeps the Hornets along with
to why reverse cleaned up light white
power
[Music]
Keiji draws the attention with slow to
get into the game offensively last night
white got a piece of that one right
there is such a bonus
[Applause]
look at Nick right there I contact the
white spin-off of white side perfect
pass Kent scan finished by the big
fellow Hornets with their starting five
on the floor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
not sit heads but you on it
see behind security Johnson Isaac since
I've dumped two times already the white
says the third time you will not on my
watch
I mean one hand
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
with some anger
blitz right there nobody picks up the
white until it's too late and new Scalla
oh you're the poster he'll be in therapy
by tomorrow all the Hornet baskets
explored by Marvin and Dwight another
blocked shot by Howard leads to the run
out numbers three on to ditch the public
played a little bit too good for their
taste they traded him down to New
Orleans shot blocked white power picks
up the loose ball and rips it through
the early
[Applause]
because it gets hot to set his shots
white how it spins off the Bulls Center
in one lob really got this team inspired
into jobs now you got a ten-point lead
[Applause]
it's me Stevie would help our brothers
send it in Annie's file or I was gonna
say guess who threw it
that is a spin move bead I can go and
run over it set up screen it just slips
that screen and simply throws it right
to the front room
[Applause]
[Music]
then the feathers guy let it be his shot
was short
Howard grosses inside its cars
oh my a ferocious start to the third
quarter for native Atlantan Dwight
Howard Nix sets the screen for the white
he turns it down runs along the baseline
picks it up foul
maybe on Grahams freshman year did he
just do that Nick took Dwight Howard is
right there read to thee look at the
white that assists LeBron James fires it
out to cream watch impressive block shot
white our bed will stay with Cleveland
Cleveland nice timing right there the
Dwight quickly off of his feet desta
ball check numbers Campbell
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right there multivitamin stretch for zit
delete so you want to go 40-0
rewarded for a rim run gets himself a
two-handed flood light on cornice takes
one wave dongzi wakens a hiccup what the
magic ointment will be maybe a little
bit more of that Howard Hoosiers set
back in 1982 his film back in 1986
classic movie back in the 80s one of the
greatest sports movies of all time
Dwight Howard the flood nice feed inside
Morris finds Howard and a quick impact
egg white Howard on a beautiful pass
from Markieff Morris he's been activated
early in this first quarter now is get
that to go on the offensive side Bradley
Beal creating for Dwight Howard who
finishes and gets fouled
Lynnette saw a whole lot of this last
season from the white house and the
Charlotte Hornets uniform drives and
dishes drives and misses